synergie la fabrique citoyenne une
plateforme participative lancé par la
député de la 5e circonscription
d'indre-et-loire sabine thilay pour qui
et pourquoi on en parle donc avec ce
métier là notre invité bonsoir
savent-ils à l'instar à qui s'adresse
cette plateforme à cette plateforme
s'intéresse s'adresse particulièrement
aux électeurs aux citoyens de la 5e
circonscription d'indre et loire
mais évidemment peut être aussi utilisé
par tout les gens intéressés de notre
département
qu'est ce que vous attendez vous des
échanges avec ses citoyens que vous
souhaitez la société jeu j'aimerais bien
que mon jeu lire mon travail de député
qui consiste à légiférer à contrôler
l'action du gouvernement et a évolué
surtout les politiques publiques soit
vraiment nourries par les gens de notre
territoire et à parce que après quatre
ans de mandat
je me dis parfois on est un peu trop
soumise aux éléments de langage de nos
groupes politiques aussi bien soit il
par des lobbys mais très peu de
remontées vraiment du territoire c'est
une manière d'affirmer votre
indépendance par rapport à ces groupes
politiques ou qu'elle vous avez
appartenu la république en marche mais
celui auquel vous appartenez le modem
est atteinte
oui c'est aussi de vraiment prendre aux
sérieuses ce rôle des députés qui les
députés de la nation et que doit aussi
agir d'une manière transparente izan et
de s'inspirer un peu de tout ce qui est
mal mais aussi des territoires en termes
de réflexion et surtout valoriser aussi
le territoire parce qu'il ya plusieurs
modules sur cette plateforme souvent
quand les femmes et hommes politiques
parlent de ses échanges avec les
citoyens c'est souvent en prévision des
échéances électorales est ce que c'est
pour vous une manière de préparer 2011
ce n'est pas une nation échéances
électorales là que j'ai dans le viseur
mais surtout de
respecter une promesse de campagne et
que j'avais fait en 2017
vous serez candidate en 2012 je serai
candidate sous quelle étiquette
politique
je suis toujours en fait j'appartiens la
majorité présidentielle je suis dans le
groupe politique modem à l'assemblée
mais je suis toujours aussi à marseille
vous êtes toujours marcheuse parlons de
cette plateforme comment ça fonctionne
est ce que c'est vous qui donnez des des
consignes qui a envoyé ses perches des
thèmes particuliers vous attendez un
retour ou alors vous attendez juste que
les citoyens vous interpelle sur les
sujets qu'ils souhaitent en fait et à
trois modules en fait que vous voyez sur
le site le premier module c'est en fait
rencontre et un module qui s'appelle
parole des territoires parce que là
aussi on veut aller à la rencontre des
acteurs mettre en avant un peu les
pépites aussi de notre territoire des
actions qui peuvent être inspirante pour
d'autre part des courts reportages et il
ya aussi des webinaires avec des
spécialistes sur quelques question qu'on
peut se poser et surtout il ya le module
un peu concertation et dans ce modèle là
on aimerait bien avoir des groupes de
travail des gens qui fassent
l'évaluation de nos politiques en amont
et en aval
ça veut dire que par exemple la loi et
galim chez nous sur le territoire est ce
que la négociation entre la grande
distribution et l'agriculteur fonctionne
ou pas est ce que les citoyens vont vous
dire si si si ça marche ça marche pas
bien en temps en temps normal et en
temps habituel c'est au contact des
citoyens c'est sur les marchés c'est
lors de réunions publiques
c'est lié au coït directement sur et au
cou vite bien sûr parce que là on peut
pas refaire des réunions de public on a
du mal à l'est sur les marchés vraiment
pour échanger donc c'est aussi utiliser
les outils numériques qui sont à notre
disposition
maintenant je vous dis honnêtement c'est
un peu une bonne bouteille à la mer
j'espère que les gens vont s'en saisir
c'est un peu un ballon tests que je
lance s'il ya une proposition de loi que
vous voulez porter est ce que ce type de
plat temps peut vous
vous aidez à la modifier à l'amendé pour
coller plus près du territoire quittait
ce qu'on s'éloigne de la politique du
groupe parlementaire
j'aimerais justement que je d'avoir des
remontées des territoires des acteurs
concernés par un projet de loi qui me
disent d'ailleurs ce projet de loi vous
aller les trouver sur notre plate forme
pour que les gens puissent s'en inspirer
compteront sont saisis pour que
justement de savoir est ce que vraiment
ça nous correspond à nous est ce que ça
nous facilite la vie ou est-ce qu'on a
des doutes sur certaines choses pour
pouvoir peser aussi sur les décisions du
gouvernement
synergie la fabrique citoyens merci
sabine et il est de nous en avoir parlé
merci à vous merci à vous